y'all look so cute together
thank you
thank you it feels feel good to finally
be uh out in the public eye you know it
goes without saying this was a bumpy
road but the fact that you guys did end
up finding each other and finding love
is a great thing so i want to first say
congratulations thank you very much
there are so many questions ling green
after what we saw last night and i think
the first thing is you know susie we are
curious like how long after iceland did
you reach out to clayton and you know
what were those next steps that were
important for you guys to take together
after that initial contact pretty much
reached out to clayton immediately i got
my i got my phone back called my parents
and then i i slid into clayton's dms and
was like hey just checking in
would love to have one more conversation
with you if you're open to it but we'll
also respect your boundaries you know
either way
um and then we talked immediately that
night for about five hours and then we
talked every night after that for
several weeks before deciding to meet
back up hmm
what was that you know what was that
first reunion like for you uh i was
nervous because i
knew and we talked about it going in
that there was no expectations let's
just
meet up and see where this goes and of
course
you know i want to put my best foot
forward i wanted to say
speak from the heart and i wanted to
hopefully yeah like see if there could
be a sec another chance but i also
understood that i'm like you need to
respect her respect her boundaries
listen to her ask a ton of questions and
let this just don't put pressure on this
just let it be a conversation and if at
the end of the weekend it goes well and
you do all those things then yeah you
may you guys end up may meeting up again
and that's the way i took it it's like
just one conversation at a time
absolutely and it sounds i think you
mentioned this last night claim that i
think you guys have met up or at least
started
contacting each other four months ago so
that would have been before the show
aired so susie for you knowing what you
guys went through together and on that
journey how did you kind of regain that
trust with clayton knowing what you had
been through with him we worked a lot to
read build trust but i mean i trusted
clayton to be an honest man from the day
i met him and he proved that to be true
and he has still proved that to be true
he has never lied or been deceitful he's
been very upfront
and that was one of the first things
that we did after the show was we just
were completely transparent not only
about our needs but also about uh you
know where our minds were at during the
journey and and after the show as well
and um i think just having that
transparency with each other and knowing
i know clayton is an honest man he was
never gonna lie to any of us that wasn't
hard to rebuild trust it was just
getting to the bottom of
where our minds were at while we were
making decisions and like with that i
know clayton has had the whole time has
had the purest intentions he's got the
biggest heart and he genuinely has
not only cared for me but he has cared
about the other moments and and the
repercussions of his actions sure were
there conditions that you kind of laid
out you know
as you're trying to establish whether or
not you wanted to get back together with
him or not yeah i guess there were i
mean as yeah i didn't i didn't want any
pressure from anybody including clayton
including myself and i didn't want to
put pressure on him either we wanted to
make sure that if we were going to show
up at afr together it was on our own
terms because we both want to be there
and i think that's why it was so
important for me to turn down that final
rose because if i had accepted it there
would have been pressure to to be there
with him so
i can say confidently both of us there
last night we were there because we
wanted to be there
and we chose each other we have chosen
to like stand through the tough stuff
together so
um i feel confident in that last night
was not easy for anybody you know i'm
sure it was tough for you guys too uh
what was that 90 minutes like for you
susie kind of watching clayton's feet
being held to the fire you know by the
other women it was really tough i mean
we we obviously knew
those conversations were coming i had
those conversations with clayton and i
was privy to having hours upon hours to
ask the questions that i needed whether
it was for closure or to continue a
relationship these women had eight
minutes or whatever it was to get their
piece and have their closure
and i think everyone did a great job
we knew it was going to be emotional and
it but it was hard to watch it was it
was just it was heartbreaking to see the
devastation from these women and we both
cared deeply about them so
it was just tough claim how did you feel
walking away from those conversations
last night with gabby and rachel also
knowing very well that you did get your
happy ending and susie's on your arm now
but i'm sure it was a bittersweet going
through that experience it was and you
know what i just wanted to
i owed it to those women to give them as
much closure as i could and there was
nothing that i could really say
besides apologizing the only thing that
i felt was right because i felt terrible
and i knew that
there was no time for explanation again
i don't think these women wanted an
explanation and it wouldn't have felt
right unless they asked for it but again
for the time that we had last night i
wanted to just let them know like hey i
am extremely sorry i don't want to make
any excuses
i wish the best for them i'm extremely
happy when when they announced that they
were dual bachelorettes i
uh you know i had a big smile on my face
because uh they're gonna both get their
happy ending as well and they and they
really do um you know they they deserve
it they deserve it they've went through
a lot and a lot of it was because the
pain i caused but i hope that at the end
of the day um you know hopefully maybe
we do have conversations on the road and
we can we can uh maybe hopefully they'll
forgive me i don't know where they stand
on that but i i i don't expect them to
but i hope they were able to get the
closure they needed are you hoping for
future conversations with them how do
you think those will go do you feel like
you got everything out that you needed
to with them you know again i don't
think they owe me
anything so i don't i don't feel you
sure like there's things that i can
explain but if they don't want
explanations then i don't then
i don't deserve to get to be able to
give them those explanations there's no
reason to
if they don't see it fit
i would always be open to talking with
both of them if they have more questions
and want to and understand because again
i'm not
one to withhold stuff i don't want to
lie i don't want them i want them to
understand what
everything i was doing i had the purest
of intentions obviously i took bad
actions but it was with no mal intent
and so again if they want to have those
conversations i'm always open to having
them if they don't then i respect that
you know clean i feel like it was also a
product because you had mentioned it
throughout the whole season that you
know it's been really tough for you in
the past to open up and to be vulnerable
and i feel like once you crack that open
you just couldn't help it i feel like
that's where that attachment started
coming because you saw a different side
to yourself through these women you know
yeah you know my family actually even
made the comment yesterday they said
we've never seen you be so open and just
i think what happened was is i did i was
fighting it fighting and fighting and
saying i'm not gonna fall in love with
multiple people it's not gonna it's just
not possible for me nor is it going to
be good
but then when i did open up yeah it we i
went into this uncharted territory of
of falling from multiple women and i had
no idea how to handle it and i i thought
i was making the right decisions but
clearly i wasn't from what i've read at
least again i don't know at the end of
the day how you really go about dating
multiple women and and and doing it in a
way where you don't hurt anyone i kind
of felt that hurting somebody at the end
of it was going to be inevitable but i
also felt that i owed it to everyone to
not hold back unfortunately again like i
see it it's tough and i i don't know if
i'd ever i would never do it again put
it that way i mean i never date i would
never date multiple women ever again
because i'm happy with one
and i honestly don't i don't know if i
was equipped to handle dating multiple
women i just don't and and so for what
it was i just feel terrible that i heard
as many people as i did well there's no
playbook to being the bachelor and so on
that note what advice do you have for
the next guy to date multiple women on
this show i think the biggest advice i
can give is to
follow your heart
ask as many questions and do not make
those assumptions don't assume just ask
questions because
the biggest mistake i think i made of
all the mistakes i did make was i
assumed that everyone was um you know in
the same headspace that i was and i
couldn't have been farther from that as
far as that truth so her assumption and
so because of that that's where uh there
was a lack of communication which led to
a breakdown in the relationships uh
because of my own doing so i would tell
any future bachelor ask a million more
questions because it's better to have
too much information than not enough i'm
curious did you both watch this season
back together or did you do it
separately and what was your reaction
susie when you were kind of watching
everything play out
it was a little bit of both we watched
it together when we could but there were
days that i watched it with friends or
family
or when i was working i would have it on
it wasn't it was actually better than i
expected in some ways but
it was tough i mean there were times
that were emotional and i was
it was just a hard situ like you know
situation to be in
um you're dating this guy and then
you're watching him fall in love with
other people so it's not it's not like
super fun but the tough conversations
ever had after you watch
they were tough conversations for sure
but the best thing that i can say and i
applaud clayton ford is that he was
transparent from the beginning we did
not jump back into this relationship
without
you know turning every stone we talked
about everything i knew where his heart
was out at every point in the journey
and so when i saw it back it wasn't none
of it was a surprise to me um i i was
full i knew what i was in for you know
so yeah it was tough there were tough
conversations there were tough moments
but i'm yeah ultimately i am really
proud of him for following his heart and
just for
being the kind compassionate person that
he is and growing so much through this
and finally what is next for youtube
we're moving to well he's moving to
virginia
he's going to condo right clinton
yeah
yeah i sold it
before i went on to the show i wanted to
um
you know i went or maybe i sold after i
can't remember but my whole thing was i
was like i want to uproot myself and
give whoever i end up with a chance like
for this to actually work and i do
believe it's important to be living
under the same roof if you really want
to give it the best chance of starting
that forever with somebody so i'm moving
in here actually flying back tomorrow
and uh and then you know about a month
from now we'll actually go back to
scottsdale grab all the rest of my stuff
out of my apartment and then we're
taking a road trip across the uh the u.s
so
we're gonna start planning all that as
far as what places we hit but it's gonna
be a lot of fun
[Music]
you